all First Amendment cases are about the
power who should have the power to tell
individuals what to read think believe
or feel
I'd like to start with the Bill of
Rights because it is the law that the
government has to obey now certainly of
course the government has to obey the
statutes that Congress passes as well
but this is our basic Charter that
defines the limits of how far government
can go with respect to the individual
and because of that I feel especially
privileged that I've had an opportunity
in my career to spend my time defending
the Bill of Rights
most Americans no one in this room of
course but most Americans really sort of
take it for granted don't really think
about how important it is until they
have some event that reminds them that
not everybody enjoys the privileges that
we take as just breathing the air my
wife a couple of years ago was traveling
in Iran she's a bioethicists and was
touring various places in the country
and talking to doctors and going to
conferences and every now and then
someone would ask her what does your
husband do and she'd tell them and
invariably that person would say isn't
that dangerous
well no not here
it's not dangerous to defend free
expression well I actually have to take
that back there was a case I worked on a
few years ago where we challenged the
constitutionality of the FTC's
do-not-call list for telemarketers and
after we at the district court level won
an injunction in that case the judge
started getting death threats so yeah it
can be dangerous but he was safe after
we lost on appeal so we'll talk not just
about the Bill of Rights but more
specifically about the First Amendment
and I think it makes sense to do that by
actually focusing on the words of the
First Amendment 45 words Congress shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press or the
right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances now you read
that you think okay this guy's a First
Amendment lawyer he must have the
easiest job in the world how hard is
that to understand
no no law you know you go black as a
justice would frequently say no law
means no law and so you know we'll apply
the First Amendment as it was intended
although justice Black said that things
like picketing were not protected by the
First Amendment fully because they were
speech plus they were more than that so
it quickly becomes apparent that
protecting the First Amendment doesn't
mean that everything involving words is
off-limits for government regulation
otherwise you could go into a bank and
the teller a note that says give me all
your money and then you could argue when
the police haul you in exercising my
First Amendment rights well no it
doesn't quite work that way you after
you've spent a little bit of time
thinking about it or working with some
of the cases you realize that the First
Amendment the terms that we're talking
about the freedom of speech and the
freedom of press are terms of art that
have been developed over years and
defined and the effort made to focus on
exactly what they mean now that has led
to a lot of legal theorizing about what
the framers intended when they wrote
these words former judge Robert Bork for
example wrote famously in a 1971 Law
Review article that the First Amendment
really protects only that speech was
which is expressly political which is
rather unsatisfying if you think how
limiting that would be former president
of Amherst College
Alexander Michael John theorized that
the First Amendment is an absolute but
again only with respect to political
speech he later revised that view
because he realized that it wasn't very
workable and he said that what political
speech includes art science music
philosophy all of those things that are
required to make political speech
meaningful so it broadened it rather
directly but one of the things that I
want to focus on tonight is the idea
that many people will argue that the
first amendment limits start with speech
that we consider speech to be of no
value this is an argument that we see
recurring again and again and a good
example of that comes with Justice John
Paul Stevens in actually his first
decision as a Supreme Court judge
a case involving zoning of adult adult
uses young versus American mini theatres
in 1974 and in that case he basically
said few of us would send our sons and
daughters off to war to preserve a
citizen's right to see specified sexual
activities exhibited in theatres of our
choice now that to him was sort of a
limited the first amendment that was
part of a plow a per lap that's easy for
you to say a plurality decision meaning
it wasn't the decision of the court but
that sentiment is something that you see
expressed again and again although
interestingly justice Potter Stewart who
famously wrote I may not be able to
intelligibly define obscenity but I know
it when I see it disagreed with that
sentiment and wrote in a dissenting
opinion that if the First Amendment
protects no more than what we would send
people off to defend then it is
circumscribed by public opinion and he
wasn't going to sign on to that
sentiment we see as I mentioned this
argument being made again and again the
FCC for example in enforcing its
indecency regulation says that it can
look at the context of speech when it's
broadcast and say that by determining
whether or not the speech is of
sufficient merit in its view whether or
not the words being used in that context
are protected or whether they're not and
the very same words may be protected or
they may be the subject of severe
penalties depending on the FCC's
determination of the context there are a
number of cases that have recently been
decided by the Supreme Court some that
are still pending that also focus on
this notion of whether or not certain
kinds of speech fall beneath the dignity
of the First Amendment and therefore
shouldn't be protected as a matter of
fact I've been told that for many of the
cases I work on I have been wasting my
career this from a fairly prominent
member of the libertarian community that
I guess I shouldn't probably mention who
that is but the point I want to make
tonight and what I want to talk about is
that I think that kind of criticism
completely misses the point of the First
Amendment
first amendment cases aren't really
about the speech they aren't really
about the underlying speech whether or
not it has merit all First Amendment
cases are about the power who should
have the power to tell individuals what
to read think believe or feel and so
regardless of whether or not you think
the speech has merit the merit is in the
freedom and that's what we try and
establish in each of the cases that
we'll be talking about tonight I'll
explore this theme in some of the cases
that I've worked on over the years now
first of all as you heard John saliano
is here with us a true First Amendment
hero someone who I had the great
privilege to help defend this was the
case that but David mentioned in Ducey
last summer the first obscenity
prosecution in DC in about 35 years now
you might ask how does the First
Amendment and the political values that
we cherish in the First Amendment relate
to an obscenity trial and I guess the
answer is easily found if you simply go
back and read George Orwell's 1984
keep in mind that the subversive act
that made Winston Smith the protagonist
a target of the state is that he engaged
in a sexual relationship he had a
personal tie that took him away from the
state that when you really think about
it there's really no more personal
connection that we are really thinking
about it and how individuals define
their own sexuality and those choices
that they make and if we give the
government the power to criminalize not
even the acts but speech about the acts
then it is an act that is deeply
offensive to the First Amendment now
again this trial took place last summer
this was the the legal team I was very
privileged to serve as local counsel in
a case that involved I think some of the
finest First Amendment lawyers in the
country
Louise Sirkin Paul cambria al Gelbart
and of course we have John here now at
the time this was taken we were looking
a little bit more than long we just been
in the midst of jury selection and so we
didn't know what the outcome of the case
was going to be at that
point this was taken immediately after
the verdict after the after judge Leon
throughout the the government's case
without our having to put on a defense
and so there are a lot more smiles here
this was taken in front of a statue of
Blackstone in front of the courthouse in
DC and so again one of the things it was
very heartening about that is that even
though many of the rulings on motions
had been unfavorable ultimately the
important motion to dismiss the case was
granted and also it was fairly revealing
to us that for members of the press that
spoke to jurors after the case the
jurors basically said we would not have
convicted him that if there is a
community standard in this country it is
let your neighbor do what he wants it's
not our business now this brings up
another case where you might wonder
where the First Amendment value as this
is the case that was mentioned in the
introduction involving phenomenon called
crush videos if you don't know what they
are I probably shouldn't go into any
great detail let's just say that they
involve women wearing stilettos doing
awful things to woodland animals the law
however that was adopted had a was was
what far beyond the issue of crush
videos in 1999 Congress adopted a law to
prohibit not the actions because animal
cruelty is already a crime they adopted
a law designed to prohibit depictions of
animal cruelty but the law itself didn't
just say we're going to do private
depictions of animal cruelty it was
written much more broadly than that it
basically said if you have any
depictions of an animal being wounded or
killed and it is illegal essentially in
any jurisdiction then you can be thrown
in jail simply for possessing that image
with an intent to sell it very very
broad language much more broader than
simply saying that you're going to go
after
fringe sexual fetish films that involve
cruelty now we were told at the time
don't worry we're not going to enforce
this law as broadly as the language
suggests we're only going to enforce the
law where we really think that there are
bad things going on where there really
is some sexual fetish involving Cruelty
to Animals had that been the intent it
would have been nice if they'd written
the law that way but they didn't and
instead we were stuck with this law but
despite the fact that it was passed
essentially unanimously by Congress with
the notion that we're going to stop
crush videos in ten years the law was
never enforced not a single case was
brought against crush videos and instead
in about 2007 and enterprising federal
prosecutor in Pennsylvania who was known
for pushing the limits of obscenity law
trying to make it broader and broader
brought a case against Robert Stevens
now Stevens is a pit bull infill
enthusiast he is also quite an expert on
the breed he's written a book called
dogs of velvet and steel he actually if
you go to amazon.com you'll find that
book 175 bucks
it's about essentially training breeding
things like that he is not a dog fighter
interestingly enough but he also had
made some documentaries not great
production values but documentaries
about pit fighting and also about
training dogs for hunting now
interestingly the pit fighting videos
we're not they didn't involve fights
that he was involved in he doesn't fight
dogs he didn't even film the the fights
they were filmed by others some of them
in Japan where dogfighting is legal some
of them decades earlier who simply
incorporated them into these videos and
so the very first prosecution under this
law adopted for Kraus videos was against
mr. Stevens 69 years old a federal SWAT
team broke down his door at 5:00 in the
morning
roust and hand his wife out of bed the
wife with a heart condition
and put him on trial he was convicted he
was sentenced to 37 months in prison
which actually snaps into perspective a
little bit when you realize that michael
vick who actually was running a
dogfighting ring was sentenced to 23
months but for putting together images
of dogfighting mr. Stevens was sentenced
to 37 months the Court of Appeals struck
down the conviction on First Amendment
grounds and it went to the United States
Supreme Court where I was
again privileged to work on that that
defense team and interestingly the
argument that the government made in
that case in support of the law was one
of the most frightening things I've seen
in my years as a First Amendment lawyer
they essentially argued that if the
government can show that speech is of no
value and that it might be harmful then
that speech is not protected by the
First Amendment at all ultimately the
Supreme Court disagreed and in an eight
to one decision said that it is
protected by the First Amendment is
excluded from the First Amendment and
described the government's theory as
being far-reaching and frightening a
fortunately a view of the First
Amendment that the Roberts Court has
continued to to uphold in cases after
that that case I think is the beginning
of a trend that we've seen in cases like
this where the government has made the
argument that there are additional
categories of speech that shouldn't be
protected by the First Amendment that
also came up again Jean mentioned in the
introduction involving funeral protests
of the Westboro Baptist Church it was
the argument was made that their
particular message which is hateful and
I think inexplicable is something that
shouldn't be protected by the First
Amendment
actually and they provoked all kinds of
reactions and we'll see a few more of
those and that's part of why the speech
is protected they're essentially a
family cult their view
is that all catastrophes that we face
deaths overseas and foreign wars are
God's retribution for America's
tolerance of homosexuality and so they
have adopted a number of techniques for
their protests including protesting in
the vicinity of military funerals now
there's something that is really not
known as well about their their form of
protest is that they're actually fairly
smart about it in that they call the
police in advance they follow all police
directives they keep the distance from
the funeral and in the case that went to
the Supreme Court they were not even
seen by the family about it by the
father who finally ultimately brought
suit until later he saw some of the
signs on television the popular
misconception is that they were there
disrupting the funeral and that really
wasn't the case I filed an amicus brief
in that case on behalf of the reporters
committee for freedom of the press and
2021 other news organizations including
such places as Dow Jones New York Times
NPR and so on because the underlying
rule First Amendment values that would
have been disrupted because of allowing
a suit to go forward against these folks
would have been devastating to the media
to First Amendment values in general
now the argument again the government
made and also the amici that supported
I'm sure not the government of the the
Snyder family made and actually 46
states filed amicus briefs in support of
the family was that again the message
that the Westboro Baptist Church brings
to us simply isn't worth it and
shouldn't be protected by the First
Amendment but again this misunderstands
the marketplace of ideas
so once person's message doesn't define
whether or not there's value in a given
communication because after all a
community the act of communication is
two-sided
there's also what is heard and what is
believed some people will see that and
think hmm maybe so most people I think
the vast majority people will see that
and say what are these people thinking
how can anyone have these ideas and
that's the marketplace of ideas
in in action in addition there is
counter speech and as you probably know
the Westboro Baptist Church tends to
provoke a lot of counter speech when
they show up anywhere to demonstrate
that is the marketplace of ideas in
action and if you don't believe that
now this isn't real of course I I just
thought it was funny but there's there's
actually a website out there where you
can go on and get this sort of
background and you can add whatever
message you want you know happy birthday
mom just whatever you'd like and you're
sponsored by the Westboro Baptist Church
but again it is the marketplace of ideas
in action now as I say this kind of
argument that we've seen in cases
involving such disgusting things as
crushed videos and silly ideas like
those espoused by the West bette
Westboro Baptist Church pop up in all
kinds of other situations as some of the
people my age in the audience an older
will remember Lenny Bruce was placed on
trial for obscenity because of his
stand-up act in three different states
in California and Illinois and in New
York he was convicted in Illinois and in
New York the conviction in Illinois was
overturned the conviction in New York
was not because Lenny died before the
conviction could be perfected George
Carlin similarly before his troubles
with the FCC was arrested for obscenity
at the Wisconsin State Fair think about
it stand-up comics being arrested in
this country for word crimes it simply
doesn't sound American and yet we have
to continue to fight these First
Amendment battles because of the
argument that is made is that this is
just trivial speech it's just jokes and
yet they're saying bad things that the
community doesn't like therefore we
should be able to make them criminals in
the case of these we have one happy
ending so far although as I say Lenny
was dead so it's not so happy for him
and we're still fighting the second one
the first one involves a posthumous
pardon that we got for Lenny Bruce in
2003 in the state of New York we
petitioned the Governor George Pataki
for a posthumous pardon and who would
have thought it would happen he granted
it at the end of 2003 basically arguing
that it's time to set the record right
for First Amendment purposes this is
Kitty Bruce his daughter and this is the
certificate from Governor Pataki we were
later celebrating was when the authors
of the book that led to the pardon
effort Ron Collins and David's cover and
book is the trials of Lenny Bruce go by
it they won the Hugh Hefner First
Amendment award that year for the book
that led to the pardon effort and that's
where I first met Katie face to face
although the day of the pardon was a
very strange day it was right before
Christmas and I remember I gotten a
little bit of warning from the
governor's office that it was going to
come down and then the press calls
started coming in and toward the end of
the day I got a call and a woman on the
other end said I know we haven't met but
I want to thank you for all you've done
my name is Katie Bruce and I keep
getting calls from reporters and they
asked me what I should tell them about
you and so I said to her well tell them
I represent living people too and
and but anyway it was quite a
celebration and you know while not much
help to Lenny Bruce I think it is
helpful to the rest of us to have a
state government officially acknowledge
30-some years after the fact that they
made a mistake and they're trying to
prosecute somebody for words that he
used even if they thought they were
silly words they're worthless words was
a mistake and contrary to the values
that we believed in under the First
Amendment
the other issue involving George Carlin
of course is still ongoing as many of
you may know George Carlin is the
stand-up comic
the legendary stand-up comic whose
monologue called filthy words better
known as the seven dirty words led to
the FCC revamping and redefining its
indecency policy in the mid-1970s
Pacifica Radio had played his monologue
the FCC heard it and they crafted an
entirely new standard for indecency
based on the George Carlin monologue now
I have to say I've been studying the
First Amendment for a long time it's the
first time I have ever seen
a legal standard created by a stand-up
comic and yet that was the standard that
the FCC employed for years and to in
many respects still employs and which
was odd because for a time I worked at
the FCC
I was chief counsel to the Chairman and
tried to work on indecency cases under
under him until finally I went to him
one day and said boss you know there
there's really actually no way we can
enforce this law constitutionally and so
fortunately he allowed me to recuse
myself and working on the indecency
cases and didn't fire me and so since
then I've been out working on cases
involving these rules trying to get them
struck down and preferring to think of
the FCC as the defendant there are as
you may know a number of cases ongoing
one involving the 2004 broadcast of the
Superbowl and yes that case is still
going on
the longest nine sixteenths of a second
in history second case involving Fox
involving unscripted
by Sharon Nicole Richie on the Billboard
Music Awards show and then a case
involving NYPD Blue that the Parents
Television Council decided was indecent
now many of these cases have been going
on for years as I mentioned and two of
them have actually been decided by
courts of appeals the United States
Court of Appeals for the Second Circuit
held that the FCC's indecency policy in
the Fox case and in the NYPD blue case
was unconstitutionally vague that the
more the FCC has to say about what it
means the less anybody understands it
and so as a result it's unconstitutional
the Superbowl case were still waiting we
have one decision from the US Court of
Appeals from the Third Circuit where it
was struck down then after an
intervening Supreme Court case they sent
it back to the Third Circuit and said
try over because the the Third Circuit
has looked at it on administrative law
grounds and I think next we'll be
finding out whether or not the Third
Circuit will look at it as a
constitutional matter but meanwhile
these cases continue to go on and even
though we have had these positive steps
these positive decisions they still
continue to take their toll for example
in 2007 it was the 50th anniversary of
the the poem howl being acquitted on
obscenity charges Allen Ginsberg was was
charged with obscenity because of a
public reading of the poem how he was
acquitted 50 years later because of the
FCC rules stations felt they still
couldn't put it on the air because
they're nervous about what the FCC might
do got a little bit of coverage and an
editorial of New York Times and an
editorial cartoon but nonetheless
stations are still nervous even two
weeks ago for those of you who aren't
from Washington they might not have seen
this story a woman went into the
National Gallery of Art and attacked the
one hundred and twelve year old Gauguin
painting to Tahitian women she said it
was an evil painting because it depicted
nudity and because obviously with two
women standing there it had a lesbian
and so as a result she had to do
something about it she tried to rip it
from the wall and fortunately it was
covered with plexiglass so she couldn't
do any damage to it but she beat on the
plexiglass with her fists now she she
also said that she was from the CIA and
had radio in her head so she's now being
fitted for tinfoil hat but nonetheless
the damage from the First Amendment
perspective is even with an obviously
newsworthy story like this news stations
were afraid to cover the the episode
uncensored this is what WJLA in
washington did they had a banner go
across the middle of the women's chests
so that you would not see breasts or or
nipples FoxNews blurred out they the
breasts others handled it in different
ways but even with two affirmative Court
of Appeals decisions saying that the
rules are unconstitutional because they
are vague even with the FCC itself
saying that certain times on the news
will say it's okay we're just not going
to tell you when we're not going to say
it's okay because of that stations are
nervous because the the penalties for
violating these FCC rules are really
very very hefty and there's it can be in
certain cases a lose your license kind
of violation there's one more case
that's still pending at the Supreme
Court and this may be oddly enough one
of the most important of them all
this is Swartz negative versus in the
electronic Merchants Association a case
involving the California law prohibiting
the sale or rental of violent video
games to young people the courts of
appeals have uniformly struck down these
laws as being a violation of the First
Amendment the Supreme Court took it up
and as heard argument we simply haven't
heard what the outcome is going to be
yet the reason it's so important is that
California is really pushing the
envelope and arguing three different
things that arguing first that violent
video games should be a new category of
unprotected speech because it's just not
important secondly they argue that kids
under 18 really don't have any First
Amendment rights anyway and then thirdly
they're arguing that these new
bangle technologies shouldn't be
protected by the First Amendment so the
underlying principles involving what you
would think is a fairly trivial case
based on just the subject matter
nonetheless turns out to be really quite
important and we don't know what the
what the courts going to do yet although
based on the oral argument we're
optimistic interestingly during the
argument the Attorney General from
California was asked so you know why are
you choosing this new area of violence
to find a new area of unprotected speech
and his response was what we had to
start somewhere so that's the sort of
mindset that you get we'll start there
and see what we want to restrict next
and that is ultimately how censorship
works in that case I filed a brief for
the comic book Legal Defense Fund for
which I serve is outside General Counsel
and we tried to point out to the court
that this really is nothing new that we
have seen these kinds of moral panics
again and again and again it was the
argument made against the penny theaters
and the penny dreadfuls in England in
the mid 19th century same argument was
made against dime novels in this country
against jazz music against cinema
against comic books in the 50s against
television beginning in the late 50s in
the early 60s and continuing today and
now against video games we've seen these
moral panics come and go and the same
arguments are being made here so that's
what's happened so far in the cases let
me just close with something they tell
you never to do with powerpoints and
that's actually to put a bunch of words
up there and I do that because as a
First Amendment lawyer I think words are
important but more importantly I think
they drive home why the principles
involved in these cases involving
seemingly trivial speech are some of the
most important principles that we've
been able to establish in the First
Amendment case law first of all United
States versus Stevens is a case that
involves as I said the images of animal
cruelty what to be important about that
but once again if you look at the
principles that the court finally came
down with in an 8 to 1 decision
it really is critically important the
First Amendment's guarantee of
does not extend only to categories of
speech that survived in ad hoc balancing
of relative social costs and benefits
our Constitution forecloses any attempt
to revise that judgment simply on the
basis that some speech is not worth it
and in seeming response to President
Clinton's trust me a statement that
we're only going to enforce it against
the really bad stuff the court went on
to say the First Amendment protects
against the government it does not leave
us at the mercy of noblesse oblige
really critical stuff involving what you
would think of as particularly trivial
and hateful speech this NIDA vs. Phelps
the case involving Westboro Baptist
Church just decided a number of weeks
ago again very hateful speech really
hard to embrace the speaker on this one
and yet the court looks beyond that and
says West Burroughs funeral picketing
certainly it certainly hurtful it is not
and its contribution to public discourse
may be negligible but we cannot react to
that pain by punishing the speaker as a
nation we have chosen a different course
to protect even hurtful speech on public
issues to ensure that we do not stifle
public debate again following an earlier
precedent involving Jerry Falwell in
hustler magazine finding that even
hateful speech should be protected Fox
Television the case involving indecency
and again this case arose from cher and
Nicole Richie making unscripted remarks
at the Billboard Music Awards show hard
to find much political content there and
yet the principle is that the government
just doesn't get to make up the rules
and then let everybody guess at what
they mean the court writes the FCC
assures us that it will bend over
backwards to protect editorial judgment
at least in the news context but such
assurances are not sufficient instead
the FCC should bend over backwards to
create a standard that gives
broadcasters that notice that is
required by the First Amendment and then
finally a case that I haven't talked
about tonight but that I think
establishes these these principles this
is a case I argued the Supreme Court
about ten years ago involving Believe It
or Not the phenomenon of
signal bleed signal bleed meaning random
images of unscrambled cable that can
somehow be discerned along with it has
also been called Picasso porn and as
part of the Telecommunications Act a
number of years ago heavy regulations
were placed on adult cable networks in
particularly playboy television the
court in a five-to-four decision said
that we cannot be influenced by the
perception that the regulation in
question is not a major one because the
speech is not very important the history
of the law of free expression is one of
indication in cases involving speech
that many citizens find shabby offensive
or even ugly and finally don't bother to
try and read this next when you'll go
blind there's a lot of words here but
this is the reason I'm a First Amendment
lawyer this was in the majority opinion
in Playboy Justice Kennedy wrote this
for the court when a student first
encounters our free speech jurisprudence
he or she might think that it is
influenced by the philosophy that one
idea is as good as any other and that if
are in the literature objective
standards of style taste decorum beauty
and aesthetics are deemed by the
Constitution to be inappropriate indeed
unattainable quite the opposite is true
the Constitution no more enforces a
relativistic philosophy of moral
nihilism than it does any other point of
view the Constitution exists precisely
so that opinions and judgments including
aesthetic and moral judgments about art
and literature can be formed tested and
expressed once the Constitution says is
that these judgments are for the
individual to make not for the
government to decree even with the
mandate or approval of majority to me
you can find no better statement of what
the First Amendment is about and I can
tell you from the standpoint of having
fought that case for a number of years
and finally argued in the Supreme Court
there is no more humbling experience
than to see the work that you have done
end up on a page with words like that
and for that reason I feel like the work
that I do every day is a great privilege
thank you
you